[Music]
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Tom Arnold are
just two of the actors coming to the
fence of their true lines co-star Eliza
Dushku after she claims she was sexually
assaulted while shooting the movie in
1993 by the film stunt coordinator he's
just the action kid
at age 12 Eliza played Schwarzenegger
and Jamie Lee Curtis his daughter in the
1994 action-packed blockbuster with
dangerous stunts like this a Ben 36
year-old Joel Kramer
Arnold's former stunt double was hired
to keep Eliza and the cast safe I don't
cross the line with anything I'll tell
somebody right away how many different
ways we can shoot this type of stuck but
this weekend Dushku took to Facebook
claiming Cramer sexually molested her
and she only told a few family members
at the time but no one seemed ready to
confront it her name until wa Eliza's
co-stars and director James Cameron have
rallied around her Tom Arnold tweeting I
promise you Jim Cameron Schwarzenegger
and Jamie Lee Curtis would have done
something to which Schwarzenegger
respondent Tom you bet your blank all of
us would have done something in a
Huffington Post op-ed Jamie Lee wrote
Dushku did share her story with her
privately a few years ago quote I was
shocked and saddened then and still am
today while Kramer has vehemently denied
her claims calling them made-up and lies
the agency that represents him WPA tells
et they've decided to part ways based on
the allegation
[Music]
you